too
トゥデイ
南極に行ってきましたもう4年前なんですけれども
そこで僕本当にいい経験させてもらいました
すっごい綺麗だったんでちょっと皆さんにを見ていただきたいと思ってちょっとだけお
見せします
南極の内陸の方にこうやってその後ビルによって走って入っていくんです
山に登って
そこで医師をとってくるんですね
僕ば当時研究者として南極観測隊に所属していてこの地球温暖化が進んで南極のこの
エリアからどのぐらい氷が溶けてくるんだろうっていうのを予測するためのデータを
出すというチームにいました
南極に滞在したのは100日間ですでその間
だいたい点灯
マイナスだいたい20度前後ですかねその後からそのぐらいの中を60日71テントで
生活をしていました
すごいこれは僕にとって本当に素晴らしい経験だったんですけれども
ここを止めて今ここをメインのフィールドにして
仕事をしていますここどこかわかりますか
わかる方いらっしゃいますか
何かこれ鹿児島県です
鹿児島県幼児マっていう島があるんですけどご存じでしょうか三島村の島です
ここにですねこの山頂付近モクモクしているところに入っていくとこんなのがあります
これ黄色いのようです
位をとって
色んなものと混ぜ合わせるとですねこのは黒っぽい粉になるんですそれを和紙の上に
置いて
こうやってクルクル丸めていくと線香花火になるんですね
今僕はですねこの島でやって線香花火日付で遊んだりとか
またこれも同じよう島なんですけれども
この海がいろちがいますよねこれ温泉あんですよ
この音声のみで収穫して遊ぼうとか
この海に潜って遊ぼうっていうそういう遊びをですねたくさん棄却して
仕事をしています今僕こんな状態ですね
本当に何かこうこっちに来てよかったなあと楽しいな幸せだなって思いながら今ぼく
生活しています今三島村役場の職員として働いているんですけれども
僕が今こう感じているみたいに本当にもっと多くの人がこういう自分の人生からくる
幸せとか充実感っていうのを感じて生きてくれたらもっと世界は面白いところになるん
じゃないかなと思って
今日はですねあの僕の人生の中から
僕なりに
経験してきて見つけ出した幸せの人生幸せな人生を生きるための7つの方法というのを
みなさんにご紹介し
しようと思います
ご紹介させてください
一つ目東大の中田がてに進学する
は無理無理って感じですよね俺もちろんこれが幸せになるための方法ですって言って
いるのではありません
大事なのは
本気になることです
こんな大きいも今日はもちろんですけどもちっちゃい目標でもやっぱり本気になって
これを解決しようとかやってみようって思わないと物事は前に進みません
今にして思うとこんな本当に大それた目標
僕は本気になってやろうって思ったことが今のこの僕よくが感じる幸せ幸福のきっかけ
大きなスイッチだったんじゃないかなって思っています
まあこうやって本気になってですねやってみたら
なんとか
滑り込むことができたんです
進学した先はですね東大の海洋研究所という研究所です海の研究所
なのでよく船に乗るんですね楽しそうでしょう
楽しいんですよその
いろんな人が寄せ集めで船に乗ってですね色んな所から来た研究者学生が寄せ集めて船
に乗って1週間とか10日とか1ヶ月とかですね
共同生活するんですお互いの研究お手伝い行って教えたり教えられたりしながら
そういう研究生活を送っていくんですね船の上でこれがね楽しいんですよ
で楽しすぎて留年しちゃいます
でもで10年したということが僕にとってはすごく
まあ大事など雪でした
そもそも僕があの
研究者になろうと思ったきっかけが横島だったんですねん
なんかいろんなとこ行ってそうだからいいなぁみたいなとそういう軽い動機で研究会
などを地質学者様になろうっていう風に考えて進んじゃったんですね
まあ挫折して
優秀な人は博士後3年とか2年とかとって卒業していくんですけど僕は全然そうじゃ
なかったで遊んでばっかりたんで
除雪しちゃいました
そこでですね高
ふと気づいたんですよ
僕あれ研究やってるけどあんまり面白くないな
全然面白くないな
でもこの墓制課程を卒業して博士後虎舞と卒業できないし
できるかどうかまずわかんないしとったところで就職わけないじゃんって言う
これぼく何やってんだろうって思ったんです楽しくないことこんな一生懸命やってっ
これ意味なんのって
そこからですねもうどん底に沈みこん者って
者僕なんで研究やってんだろうとかなんで生きてんだろうっていうふうに考えるように
なりました
それから
この泥沼の状況を打開する二つの出来事がありました
一つ目がですねあ
大学のとき僕サークルに入ってたんですけれどもその時の友達が電話くれたんです
多挿元気
今空いとるのもや東京人によってくれて
でまぁ当然学生の僕暇なんでそれに行ったんですね
やってみたら彼遊びに来たのかと思ったらスーツ着てるんです
もう服だったんですね
どうしたのって聞いたら
友達が自殺をしたと彼は答えましたね
当時カレーはですねあのいわゆる大企業一例の企業に勤めていました
そういういわゆる勝ち組って言われるような人生を歩いている人でも自殺っていうこと
をすることがあるんだなと思って
僕はこの時結構な衝撃を受けたんです
振り返ってみると自分もそうなんですね東大の博士過程っていわゆるエリートみたいな
ところなんですけれども
そこにいる僕って全然者を知らないと言う
そのことが
自殺をした彼とすごく自分でリンクして
この時僕は本当に自殺しようとまでは思ってはいませんでしたけれども気持ちわかる
なって思ってたんです
それからもう一つこんな出来事がありました
中学校の同窓会に参加したんですね十何年かぶりにある女の子とお話をしてて
お元気仕事何してるのみたいな話をしてたんですけれども
その後はほぼさんやってるって言って
家給料安いのよとかですねなんかなかなか休み取れなくてみたいなそんな感じで
ちょっと面白くない愚痴っぽいのがちょっと出てきてたんですね
ねぼく何かそれちょっとやだなーと思って話し変えようと思っても子供好きなん
でしょうって話を振ったんです
そしたらこれですねウンコの好きなのよーって言ってくれて
その時の英学すごい輝さんです
それから応援園とですね子供かわいい話をしてくれてその話を僕延々と聞きながら長い
なと思ったんですけど
でもこの子は幸せだなって思えたんですね
この2つの出来事を見てみて
しあわせって何だろうって言っ
考えたんです
少なくとも
自分が好きなことが何かというのは買ってその近くで生きるっていうのは大事な要素な
んじゃないかなってへ
思ったんですね
もちろんあのすべての大企業の人が服をではないしすべての
そうやって来さんの人が幸せでもないと思うんですけれども
大事なのは自分の好きなことが何かをわかってその近くにいるっていうことなんじゃ
ないかなって思ったんですね
こんなフレーズが頭に浮かびました
思い当たる節ありますよねありがとうございますアンパンマンと言ってくださいました
ねうん
なにが君のしあわせなにをしてよろこぶ
アンパンマンですね
昨日のように書きました
あの
これってすごい重要なことなんですよ
僕本当に散々勉強して帰宅んですけども人生で一番大事じゃないかって思えるぐらいに
大事なことですよねこれって
なのにそんなことを習ってないじゃんって
受験勉強をいっぱいしてきたけれども人生勉強ってなんかしてなかったなーって思って
これ
て
すごい大事なことをし広めなきゃいけないんじゃないかって思ったんです
日本に今3万人くらい自殺者が毎年いるんですけれどもそれもこのアンパンマン先生と
の対応が足りてないっていうのが結構重要な事なんじゃないかなって思ったんですこれ
伝えなきゃ
幸せになるための3つ目の条件アンパンマンと話す
これは内政ですね自分が本当にどういう時に幸せを感じるとか何を以って面白いと思う
っていうことを自分で分かっていることというのが大事なんじゃないかって思ったん
です
じゃあ僕は
一体何が幸せなんだろうって考えたときに出た答えがこれでした
なんか研究者やろうと思ったきっかけがいるのとこに行くんだったんですけどやっぱ
それって好きなことなんですね僕は
本当に地球のために研究をするとか人類の未来の知識のために研究するってそういうや
ないことを言ったらいいんですけどもうこれを音なんですよしょうがないんです
誰に何と言われようが僕の本音で僕はもうしょうがないからいろんなところに行くって
いう目標のため日数学者になろうって決めたんですね
それでもう腹が決まりました
は結構そっからは早くてなんか
うまいことよっ
集中もできてガンバレて何とかあ最後がとりそうになりました
そこで
当日痛く先生からこんなお話いただきました
前の研究
あそこの研究で継続してやれーそうなんだけどあそこの募集がかかるみたいなんだけど
かかってるんだけどどう
行ってみない今のタイミングだったらひょっとしたら集進行できるかも熱帯なことを
言ってくださったんです先生が
僕はこの留年もしてるわけですから
優秀な研究者ではないことは自分で重々分かっていて大学のポストとかって今ほとんど
ないので
主人公で撮ってもらえるって言ったらもう自分にとっては本当に喉から手が出るほど
ありがたい話研究をやっていけるって言うのですね
カーンともあるかもしれないって思ってますまた頑張れるんですそんな時に悪い先輩
たらこんな遅いいただけました
居酒屋です
内閣行ってみたいー
観客の世論のある山中というところにその多いで入っていってまぁキャンプありながら
1とってくるんだよね
そんなことやったやった人間って多分家を去ったことある人より少ないんだよね
でも3年で人気首てるからねあなたとどうにかして自分で言われたんです
これどうしようと思って
当時の僕に復帰ははっ
究極の2択ですねでわー
研究の左側の方だとわりと堅いガードで自分のラインは持って研究者としてやって
いけるそうだなという感じではあるんですけれども
何興味がいけないんです
なきゃいいん
ただ
いや行ってみたいんですけどてを3年できて来られるんですよねで僕は
鳥分野が全然変わっちゃうんで研究者として実力がない自分にとってはもう何か落ちる
ことがわかっている橋を渡りに行くようなもんで裸同然なわけです
さあどうしようっ
アンパンに相談だと
相談しました
で
相談した
結果もあるんですけどやっぱり僕このアンパンマン先生の教えをですねいろんな人に
広めたいと思ったんですよ
そのためには自分が堅いガードをしながら
何か好きなことやれよって誰かに言うよりも
いや俺な曲入ってきたんだよってその後何か仕事なくて
ホント大変だったんだけどでも行って良かったんだからお前もしないことやれよーって
言えた方が説得力あるなあと思って
じゃあ行こうと思って言ってやったんです
だからさ
花花になっちゃったんですよ本当にもうこれは去って行ったというのが正直なところで
もう先の事なんてどうせわかんないんですね3年後
のことなんてもう行ってやるしかないと思って言ってみなさいってみました
行ってみたら最初にちょっとお伝えした様なものすごい経験が出来て
本当にがこんな景色が式場があったのかっていう景色をですね毎日見せてくれるんです
よ地球が
そこでやってるのは本当に最先端の素晴らしいサイエンス本当に世界で最先端の事を
やらせてもらえて僕の研究者としての能力もすごく引き上げてもらえて
なんか人間力ってよくわからないものがついたような気もするし
南極のマイナス何十度という世界で生物の方へとして生き抜くってどういうことか
みたいな
日本じゃ全く入らない能力が身につきました
というわけ
小川なんかの4つの方法これですね南極で裸になる
これを実行するということですアンパンマン先生とお話をしてその後で決めたことを
ちゃんと自分で実行するこれですね
僕はおっしゃっていうガッツポーズだったんですけど
やっぱなんかねー違和感があるんですよ
授業の準備とか
公演の準備こういう公園頼まれ事はちょこちょこってきたんでこういう公演の準備って
いうのはすごく好実が入って集中してできるようになってなんですけども
やっぱり研究にはそんなに高入り込むことができなかったですね熱中できなかったん
ですで熱中できないところか
なんかもう体が拒否反応を起こすんですよね
いつかへ去っても文章が全然目に入ってこないとか
頭どんどん他の方に広がっていっちゃうという感じで
全然研究できない本当に
進まなくなっちゃったんです
周りの研究者とか先生とか
友達とか後輩とかは将来こんな研究が痛いなとかあんな研究者になりたいな
あの人学校やな研究者かっこいいよねっていうあの子するんですけど全然そんなのはい
てこなくて
代わりに何かいや今俺こんなことやってんだよとか
うちの研究所でこんなこと面白いことやってるよっていうの面白さを伝えるとか
頭はそうやって伝えて面白いねって言ってもらうことは僕すごい好きだし楽しいなって
思ってたんです
僕がじゃあ研究者として生きていくのってこれ正解なのみたいなことを考えて悩んで
いる時に今のこの
三島村での話もらったんです
島凝っちゃってなんかと
まぁまた悩みました
研究者というのはまあ掘り下げていく突っ込んでいく仕事なんですけどまぁなんとか
まぁ希望的観測ではあるけど
研究者としてもやっていけるんじゃないかなみたいな雰囲気は何か買って自分を持って
たんですね
新まお越しの方はまあ明らかに自分に向いているし面白そうだし好きだーー仕事だろう
なとは思うんですけども
じゃあ実際に僕がそこに踏み込んでいって例えばに就職したところで周りの人とうまく
やれるんだろうかとか
島の人に受けてもらえるんだろうかとか
いうか村役場に就職するんだったら稼ごう入らなかったじゃんみたいな感じになって
くるわけですよね
俺の10年一体何言ったいな
でありあるの話を奨学金使うですね所まあ
借金増やしながらこれは一生懸命やってきたことをやっぱなくて良かったすーみたいな
ことには親に親にも言えないんじゃないですか
どうしようと思ってパンパンに相談しました
まあまあアンパンマン先生がこう答え出してくれたら良かったんですけどわからなかっ
たんですよ本当に
周りの先輩とか先生も僕は研究者になるものと思って指導してくれてたので
蔵飛ちゃうラーってというか僕本舗理由
いやな研究から逃げたいだけじゃないのみたいなそういう葛藤もあったんですねわから
なくなって
どうしようって思ったところで
別の先生が出てきました
ルース子先生ですね
考えるな感じろと前がワクワクするなどチラッ的簡単ですよ
わくわくするほか
入っちゃったんですね
裸にまたなっちゃいました
そうやってなんでとりあえず飛び込んでみた結果が最初お話しした
この島でこうやって遊んでますっていうお話なんですね
それはまあただ行って遊びのとこ最初紹介しましたけど
もともと指令だった研究者の先生たちに島に来てもらって一緒に研究を進めたりとか
学校に教えに行ったりみたいなこともちょっとずつできるんだったんです
女子車まさにこんな感じで本当に今まで生きてた自分の人生が全部ここで花開いている
っていうそういう感覚が僕を持っているんです
幸せになるために乳首爪の方これですブルースリーと話す
これは
十分本当に考えて考えて考え詰めたら最終的にはこの自分の感覚
どっちが面白そうかどっちがワクワクするかっていうのを
大切にして選んだらいいんじゃないかなって思うんです
僕はまあこうやってアンパンマン先生と相談して自分の中身のことを考えて最終的に
ブルースリー先生に毎月なことでとどっちがワクワクするんやみたいな感じで考え
考えるんじゃない感じのって
言われてでそうやって話して決めたことを実行してきたのですごい幸せになれたん
だろうなって思うんですねで僕が多分このサイクルを今からグルグルグルグル回して
いけばたぶん僕は
西尾せてやり続けるんじゃないかというふうに思っているんですね
というわけで6つめの方法これですやつだと話しで裸になり続ける
継続ですね
まぁ今までこうやって6つですね幸せになるための方法っていうのをご紹介してきまし
たけれども
夏目にご紹介したのはこれです
今の話全部忘れてください
というのはこれは僕が幸せになった方でしかないんです僕はこういう感性を持ってきて
こういう人生あるんん歩んできてこういう経験して
こういう決断をしたから幸せになれたっていうだけの話で皆さんが僕じゃないんですよ
ね
関西違うし考え方も違うし経験も違いますだから似たような状況になった時に同じ決断
をしたとしても多分
商戦にはなれないかもしれないわけですだから結局これ今の話全部打ってください
というわけで一体この話なんだったんだろうと言う感じですけど
誰にでべきできる幸せの人生を送るための7つの方法実はなても入りません
これ1つでいいんですそれは一番最初にお伝えした本機スイッチを入れることです
自分が幸せに幸せな人生を送ろうと思って自分の人生を今から幸せに生きるっていう
スイッチをガチッと入れる
まずはそれそのスイッチを入れて持って帰ってもらいたいと思いますありがとうござい
ました